oh there's gonna be a lot of bad Russian
accents in this movie and I'm kind of
looking forward to it
[Applause]
[Music]
so first trailer for Black Widow coming
out next year I'm I'm gonna I'm not
gonna lie I'm kind of excited for this
I'm very excited for what it could be
and what it looks like based on the
trailer is very much in line in terms of
what I kind of hope the movie is and
that doesn't happen to me very often
kind of on two levels the first is I
generally try to avoid having at least
an overly specific idea of what I want
something to be because I know the more
firm and idea I have of what I wish it
was the more it's gonna let me down when
it when it inevitably isn't that because
I almost never end up getting something
that is you know if I let my brain go
that place
go that place and think oh I hope it's
this I almost never get it and least so
far it's varying the direction of being
what I want so what what is it that I
want out of this I want a I want a spy
movie I want an espionage movie I want
minimal if not non-existent super powers
like super skilled people sure you know
Hawkeye Natasha they they have skills in
excess of what a normal human being will
be able to pull off but like I don't
want the superpowers in this I don't
want the world to be threatened I want
this to be a smaller scale more personal
story to the characters because honestly
the Avengers what happened to that movie
and Black Widow and Natasha getting
involved with that that should have been
the biggest thing she'd ever been a part
of up to that point in terms of scale
size of threat etc so I don't want to
see a
because this is a prequel that
establishes that that is the kind of
thing she's dealt with before and this
doesn't look like that because this is
bringing town to personal level and
having her encounter and reconnect with
people from Russia from the former
Soviet Union that our family she is left
behind and that's the kind of setup you
use to do a story that is that has
stakes that are personal rather than
global instead of going for a big threat
that's going to destroy everything you
go for a direct personal threat that
means something to her and that that's
what I want out of this I want I want a
spy story that's personal and look at
this I think I might get it now I'm only
going to acknowledge this briefly and
then move on from it right now in this
moment the sort of complicated
frustration I've had in the last year or
so a year or two year and a half I guess
with Scarlett Johansson in general isn't
dampening my enthusiasm which is good
because as much as she has kind of
frustrated me as a you know in terms of
some stuff she's done with projects and
some things that she's said in the in
the last you know year in a bit I don't
think she's a bad person so I I it's not
a situation like I I can't watch a movie
with Kevin Spacey right now and I hope
maybe I can again Monday but I can't
right now
so I really hoped it was gonna be
anything like that because like it's
comparison isn't even there I'm just
frustrated with her but that doesn't
seem to be entering into the case which
is a relief because I was looking
forward to this movie and I didn't feel
any of that baggage watching this and
also it's worth noting that didn't
really enter into when I saw endgame
either but then again she was a part of
a whole
wasn't about her in that so I didn't
know if I could count on that as a test
bubble and now I'm gonna get a whole
bunch of people asking for details on
why I'm I know I'm frustrated with her
I'm not gonna get into it it's not worth
it for me just moving on I've already
spent too much time talking about that
so like I forgot some of the other
people who were gonna be in this I
forgot Rachel Weisz was gonna be in this
and I like her a lot of pretty much
always like her I didn't realize David
haters in this that made me happy you
just this you know with the beer in this
big a Suzy azzam that he just got aha
oh that that that was good that was fun
to see I really enjoy that and it's kind
of its kind of ironic given that he
spent a fair chunk up stranger things
season three picking on him making fun
of a Russian aji now he's playing a
Russian guy I don't know I kind of get
enjoyment out of that I'll tell you what
was really cool well I made me go home
was Natasha facing off against the other
the other woman who she calls sister I
assume it to be metaphorical I don't
think any of these people are blood
related but you've got the two of them
and they like they become you know into
a doorway in perfect time in perfect
sync exact same new method of holding a
gun and then they basically start mirror
fighting they start doing the exact same
moves on each other like they both go
for the others gun and now well they
took the others gun and lost their go so
the right back where they started I love
watching them completely mirror each
other in terms of what they were doing
in the fight and for as much as these
people of the same training they're
uneven ground on the battlefield is kind
of a cliche
in terms of action movies especially
anything that you know where there's a
direct one-on-one rival going on for as
much as I've heard that nonsense to
death I don't think I've ever seen a
literal mirroring of fight moves like
this it was so cool and it makes me
excited not just because that looked
cool but that's inventive why is it I'm
not gonna say definitively that's never
been done before but I've never seen
that before
and that and seeing an action scene that
inventive that makes you know oh what
else are they gonna come up with that
and that's the kind of stuff that can
get me excited it can be tough to get me
excited for action scenes my my feelings
about action scenes are not dissimilar
to my feelings about like say horror
movies I I'm really picky but when I
love something it's it can blow me away
when action scenes truly knock me out of
the water like they will stick with me
forever like I don't love the movie
atomic blonde I don't think it's is all
that great but holy crap the apart of
the the fight that spans across the
apartment and the way that fight goes
down wow so many of the action scenes in
Mad Max fury road John wick duh but
sometimes sometimes an action scene can
just get me in like yes and it does take
something special because most action
scenes I'll enjoy but they don't like
leave a lasting impact and it's why
while I can enjoy an action movie I kind
of need to be more than that I need to
have a decent plot good characters you
know something else going on other than
just hey action kind of like I can't
watch a horror movie before hey look at
the gore like it's not enough but that's
a really inventive action scene and it
kind of makes me like cross my fingers
and hope
yeah you folks know me I'm nitpicky
I'm nitpick is hanging might bring zeros
in Oh what could go wrong I just saw a
whole bunch of stuff I really liked that
really made me excited I guess I just
the only concern for me is like I hope
they don't try to overly tie it into
stuff that we know about the MCU kind of
like how they're they did not need to
cover Nick Fury losing his eye but they
stuck it into Captain Marvel and that
connection didn't need to be made and I
kind of hope they don't cover Budapest
which got alluded to but you know
between Clinton Natasha I don't want to
find out like I don't want them to make
connections the connection is Black
Widow its Natasha it's her I don't need
a ton of other stuff to interlink that's
been referenced so just don't do that I
guess that's about the only thing that
I'm worried about that I think they
might do and even that that's not like a
massive fear it's not like that would
ruin the film for me if they do that I
just hope they don't cuz they don't need
to that's it's kind of gimmicky it's not
necessary just give me a just give me a
good spy story and some cool action and
it's hard to know how good the story's
gonna be in spy service can't get over
convoluted and trip over themselves
again atomic blonde but the bits and
glimpses I'm getting here the scale the
action the characters the glimpses that
I'm getting this is all good stuff I'm
surprisingly excited for this not that I
wasn't excited before but I'm excited
right now at a level that is surprising
me a little bit yeah Black Widow trailer
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down let me
comment so let's talk about it put some
other stuff to do like subscribe follow
me on Twitter and other social support
me on patreon whoa
wouldn't that be amazing all that stuff
you can do or you also don't have to
because at the end of the day your
counsel I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this counsel is a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]